[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us the government
is being urged to do more to help the
vulnerable people as freezing
temperatures take hold across Britain
the fuel poverty charity National energy
actions there's millions of people will
be left struggling to stay warm and safe
at home cold weather payments of 25
pounds have already been triggered in
some postcodes and with severe weather
warnings in place the National Grid has
also said its margins are expected to be
tighter over the coming days Skies
shiman Freeman Powell reports from a
warm bank which provides shelter for
people during a cold snap
this is usually a place of worship but
now this church in Croydon is also being
used as a place for people to keep warm
offering friendship food and free
heating to those in need it is
absolutely essential for the community
for people who are struggling for people
who don't have the resources and just
want somebody to give them hope
encouragement warmth food and help them
to back out and face the rest of the
week thousands of warm banks have been
set up by councils Charities and
Community groups across the country
this one at Maxwell Park only opened
last week concerned that many won't cope
with Rising energy bills alongside
plummeting temperatures people that
having to make hard decisions really
about whether they can in fact turn
their heating on at home whether they
have got enough food to feed themselves
or their children
people are having to make really
difficult choices and now we're having
this really cold snap as well it's only
emphasized it and as the cold snap takes
grip across the UK cities up and down
the country face similar issues
Charities are working to help families
meet their very basic needs but even
their help only goes so far children who
go up in low-income households more
likely to do badly at school more likely
to struggle in the jobs Market when they
become adults themselves more likely to
experience long-term health conditions
so poverty living on a low income not
having the heating on doesn't just have
consequences in the here and now it has
long-term consequences for people
millions of people on the lowest incomes
will get a 25 pound cold weather payment
to help them get through winter but
Charities warn that this can only be a
short-term fix and doesn't go far enough
to address the poverty likely to impact
generations to come Shimon Freeman
Powell Sky News
foreign
ER joins me now another very cold
morning Steph what can we expect in
terms of how long this cold snap is
going to last
yes you're certainly not wrong it is
very cold at the moment the sun hasn't
even come up here so we've got no help
with the temperatures at all at the
moment
um it got down to minus nine last night
so that's about what it is in parts of
Oxfordshire at the moment
um very cold for many of us and this
cold snap is going to last for about a
week so it does look um like it's going
to be pretty pretty cold for many of us
what we'll see is subtle changes in the
wind direction and that will bring us a
slight change in where the showers are
so currently we've got a flow from the
Arctic that's why it's so cold so in the
far north of Scotland we're seeing quite
a few showers a lot of those are turning
wintry as you might expect but we're
also we've been watching during the
night some showers just drift down the
East Coast as well in East Anglia
there's one or two snow flurries around
at the moment those are generally going
to ease though as the wind's coming
round and instead we'll see the most of
the showers around the West so we see
them in the western parts of Scotland
the Northern parts of Northern Ireland
and the Republic of Ireland and down
towards the Northern parts of Wales as
well so that's where we'll see the
showers over the next few days by the
coast because they have picked up a bit
of moisture they'll generally be of rain
but the further Inland they managed to
get the greater the chance there is that
Beltone wintry and over any High Ground
at all they're likely to be snow so
that's what we're looking at over the
next few days we're chasing the showers
around the coast and it's going to stay
okay Steph thank you
Christmas post will stop today as Royal
maker Royal Mail workers begin a wave of
strikes in the run-up to Christmas
whilst guys mileno veselinovich joins me
now from a picket line in central London
morning Milena what are you hearing from
striking male workers down there
morning well Christmas route will be
impacted but the workers here say they
simply had no choice because the best
and final offer from the Royal Mail was
nine percent pay rise over 18 months but
with some conditions attached and those
conditions the workers here say risk
turning Royal Mail into something Akin
of a gig economy company something like
uber which they say would really
jeopardize the future of their workers
and their families now on the other hand
the Royal Mail is saying that the union
is holding customers to Ransom by
organizing this striking the run-up to
Christmas their busiest time they say
they made what is a generous offer but
that the talks have Clearly Now broken
down now postal workers will be
gathering in central London and in
picket lines like this one across the
country today to fight for their cause
but this is the Royal Mail the only
company facing strike actions in the
next few weeks you've got rail workers
you've got University staff nurses
driving examiners ambulance staff all
taking part and walking out at some
point over the next few weeks in what is
swiftly turning into a winter of true
discontent it certainly is Millennia for
now thank you
still to come on the show as thousands
of Royal Mail workers begin a series of
strikes today we will be speaking to the
General Secretary of the communication
Workers Union Dave Ward that's at 7 30
this morning
Labor's Shadow Home Secretary Yvette
Cooper she'll be in a studio with us
just after eight o'clock
as Russian forces shell the front line
in the Donetsk region in eastern Ukraine
I'll get the latest on the conflict with
Ukrainian MP Kiera ruddick
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt will today
outline how the government plans to
boost growth and competition with a
major shake-up of the UK's financial
sector expected to cut red tape and
replace EU regulations a political
correspondent Rob Powell joins me now uh
Rob what can we expect from this yes so
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt in Edinburgh
today and this is being built by the
government as the biggest overhaul in
decades of how financial services are
regulated in terms of what specifically
it would be involved lots of different
rules will be looked at and reviewed one
of them that I think is going to be one
of the main ones is around this
technical thing called ring fencing that
was essentially brought in after the
2008 financial crisis and forces Banks
to essentially legally separate off the
retail part the bit that you and I will
use from the riskier investment arms of
their Bank as well that will be looked
at again and for banks that don't have
so much investment activity those
obligations um May well be scaled back a
lot of EU rules rules that came from the
European Union on how financial services
are regulated will also be looked at
potentially reviewed and some of them
repealed as well I think in terms of the
criticism of this some may worry of
course whether after what happened in
2008 in the financial crisis its right
to loosen rules and whether that makes
crises of that sort more likely again in
the future I think for the government
though you can see multiple political
boxes it's trying to tick with this
really one is to try and show that after
leaving the European Union those
freedoms can be exploited and to try and
show some of the benefits I guess of
brexit to the financial services sector
I think another as well when Rishi sunak
is sort of Under Fire for how he is
going to promote growth in the economy
amid an Autumn statement where taxes
were going up and even though you might
not hear them too vocally now yes
concerns on the back benches about where
what impact those tax Rises will have
this allows him to point to another
policy option I think that is designed
to Spur economic growth that said it may
well be outweighed by some of those
worries around tax Rises around the
impact that will have on the economy and
growth and other concerns of course
around cost of living and strike action
as we've been hearing more widely this
morning okay Rob certainly many fiscal
challenges piling up for this government
thank you so much
let's have a look at some of today's
other headlines now and U.S basketball
player Brittany Greiner she's on her way
home to the U.S after a prisoner swap
with a Russian arms dealer known as The
Merchant of death Miss Greiner was
arrested at a Moscow airport in February
for possessing cannabis oil and was
facing a nine-year prison sentence she's
expected to arrive in the United States
in the coming hours
Backstreet Boys member Nick Carter is
being sued for sexual battery after an
alleged incident with a teenager in 2001
court documents seen by Sky News alleged
that Mr Carter invited a 17 year old
into his tour bus and forced her into
performing sexual acts his lawyer has
denied the allegations
who has been handed a suspended prison
sentence for causing the death of Harry
Dunn by careless driving in 2017. the
former U.S spy fled the UK just 19 days
after his death claiming diplomatic
immunity did not return to the UK for
her trial or sentencing but Sky News
caught up with Miss seculas as she left
her solicitor's office in Washington
after appearing in court via video link
what words do you have for Harry Don's
family today
being Justice for three years
it's three years too long for this
family to wait for justice
[Music]
to attend court in the UK
thank you
the pope has broken down during a prayer
for peace in Ukraine Pope Francis was
giving a traditional prayer on Rome's
famous Spanish stairs when he wept while
mentioning the suffering of ukrainians
the crowd applauded and urged him to
continue praying
labor has said it will introduce a new
Fast tracking process for migrants from
so-called safe countries and a bid to
clear the backlog of Asylum claims it
wins if it wins in the next election the
party cited home office figures showing
that of 7 000 albanians who made Asylum
claims after traveling to the UK in a
small boat in in June less than one
percent have had their case determined
domestic abuse charity Hestia says it's
seen a 158 increase in the number of
people getting Support over the past few
months they claim the cost of living
crisis has made it harder for women to
escape their abusers the TSB Bank has
launched an emergency flea fund to help
victims leave abusive relationships
now the drummer of rock band The
stranglers has died at the age of 84.
golden brown
[Music]
whose real name was Brian John Duffy
passed away after years of ill health he
was a Founder member of the group famous
for songs including golden brown always
the Sun and peaches
to the World Cup in Qatar now where the
quarterfinals are set to get underway
with Croatia taking on Brazil this
afternoon before the Netherlands play
Argentina this evening Aleister bunkel
is standing by for us in the capital
Doha good morning to you Ali what's the
atmosphere like over there the
quarterfinals finally here
yeah it's been a couple of days of quiet
really because there's been no football
for the last few days as the teams at
the left still in the tournament the
eight sides are in final practice and
training ahead of their quarterfinal
matches it is much quieter here than it
was during the group stages which is to
be expected because so many teams have
now gone home and with their fans but
the big matches uh do start tonight
there are no weak links left in the
tournament by the time you get to the
quarterfinal stages and today we see the
two major South American teams so as you
say we've got Croatia against Brazil
first Up 3 P.M UK time 6 p.m here
um Brazil looked a very very good side
in their last match scoring four goals
within the first half hour against South
Korea and then later on it's Lionel
Messi's Argentina who are taking on the
Netherlands which was bound to be a
cracker of a match so a lot of focus now
again on the world cup over the next 48
hours as these the finals play out and
the team survive for a position in the
semis
bearing for
food as they face France
yeah well England again in training
today there'll be at Eve of the match
Press Conference held by Gareth
Southgate and the player later on this
evening here in Doha uh Declan rice the
West Ham midfielder who was a bit poorly
uh during the week is back in training
which is good news for England and
English fans Raheem Sterling who of
course flew back home because of a
burger at his house he's due back in
Qatar today so we'll see whether or not
because of that short break that he's
had from being back home whether or not
he factors into Gareth southgate's plans
for tomorrow night but he has been a key
partying Squad so it wouldn't be a
surprise if he comes straight back into
the squad the French side as well very
well known to England I mean the two
captains for example Harry Kane and Hugo
Loris the French goalkeeper both play at
Tottenham Hotspur together so a lot of
the side know each other know each
other's games it's going to be a very
very close match Hard One to call but
there is a lot at stake because whoever
wins goes through the semi-finals and a
route potentially to the final itself
absolutely Ali thanks so much we'll see
you later Ali bunkel there across uh
developments for us at the World Cup in
Doha
well let's go back now to our top story
the cold weather and the warning this
morning that millions of people are
struggling to heat their homes as
freezing weather now takes hold well I'm
joined by the director of policy at the
fuel poverty charity National energy
action Peter Smith a very good morning
to you Mr Smith thank you for joining us
now we had a fairly mild Autumn we were
hoping for a mild winter given the
energy crisis and pressures this winter
but this cold snap is here and it's not
going to be a short one what are you
hearing about how what people are
worried about
well these are the precise conditions
that we've been so concerned about in
the build up to Winter we know that
millions of households are suffering
from cold homes and that impacted their
physical and mental health
we know that many households are left
with a desperate choice of do they
ration their energy use to try and save
money much to the detrimental to their
physical or mental health or do they get
into unmanageable levels of debt um and
despite the government assistance that's
that's there at the moment we know that
many households are choosing a former
um particularly those households with
medical conditions which can be badly
exacerbated by Cold homes aren't well
protected by the current support schemes
the targeted support schemes and are a
particular risk as we continue to see
freezing conditions
Outlook has forecast uh that energy
could be tight this week because of this
cold snap more people using uh their
heating How concerned are you about the
energy Supply lasting through the winter
well increasingly concerned uh we've
known for some time that due to a lack
of gas storage and just use the amount
of waste in our homes energy waste in
our homes that the energy system will be
particularly tight especially during a
cold snap we're obviously hoping that
the government at the regulator and
Industry themselves have prepared well
for these type of scenarios but we are
hearing continued rumors that that
um the Energy System might require
things like rolling rolling
um uh shortages and it is real it is a
real concern if we get into rotor
disconnections that we don't have the
contingency there to support the most
vulnerable people
uh now your organization that National
energy action has estimated that around
8.4 million UK households will be in
fuel poverty from April next year that's
around twice what it was a year ago if
I'm not mistaken can you explain to us
what it means to be in fuel poverty
it's simply whether or not household
needs to spend a huge proportion of
their income trying to stay warm and
safe at home we've seen um all the sort
of factors that feed into high fuel
poverty levels cut coming through in the
last year year and a half either in
terms of lower incomes or flatlining
incomes soaring Energy prices and energy
inefficient housing stock which
continues to be the cold man of Europe
so those factors combined mean that
we're particularly exposed to seeing
high levels of fuel poverty but what
require what is triggering that big big
jump up in April is the withdrawal in
some instances of some of the universal
support that the government has is
currently providing as well as a lack of
coverage of the more targeted support
they are going to be put in place so we
are going to see a big jump up almost
overnight in the level of fuel poverty
uh into into next spring
and what needs to be done to avoid this
what help do people need to catch them
from falling into fuel poverty
that was put um in place in May by the
then chance for a now prime minister was
Set uh set at a level uh which um which
far which now is far exceeded by the
where Energy prices have got to so even
this winter we're still calling on the
government to do more to put more money
back into people's pockets or take more
money off people's bills to address the
immediate impact and you can continue
with that approach and we're going to
need to see a continuation of that
approach to Bear Down on the energy
costs themselves or to provide Target
income supplements but really we need to
continue to roll up our sleeves on
Energy Efficiency one of the reasons
that we're so exposed to this energy
crisis is the inefficiency in our homes
which leaks heat often much quicker than
we can pump it into our buildings so we
do need to look at that uh overriding
cause
uh now the 25 pound uh winter fuel
payments the week have been triggered by
the government in some postcodes this
week is that enough is that enough to
help people
well we do welcome that support going
out to people it's vital that people
have some confidence about heating their
homes particularly during this cold
weather snap but those limits have been
in place for over a decade now and in
that time we've seen Energy prices
double and come April they'll be pretty
much triple what they were when that um
25 pound limit was set so we do need to
see the government look at that it's um
also the case that in some parts of the
country particularly in Scotland those
payments won't be made during the
exceptional cold weather that we're
facing at the moment those 25 pound
payments or sorry a 50 pound payment
will be made in February so you know
that's a long way off for some
households and we do need to see more
immediate supports in in addition to
that I would I would also say that those
cold weather payments are often paid in
arrears and whilst we're experiencing a
very cold snap at a prolonged cold snap
at the moment often households don't
know that those payments are going to be
triggered and so they don't know upfront
that or not they can heat their homes
only retrospectively so we do need to
look at the system as well as the as
well as the financial amounts
and what would be your advice to people
who are worried about this cold weather
and worrying about how to pay their
energy bills
well first of all if people are already
in debt then they should be contacting
their supply front help repay that debt
in a way that doesn't stretch them to to
um to to the Limit financially
um but but overridingly do you
prioritize particularly if you've got a
medical health condition spending money
on on trying to keep warm it can be
decimating for your health if you are um
continue to live in cold conditions and
do struggle with um particular medical
conditions and despite Energy prices are
being at record highs there is some
government support that's offsetting
that and if you're doing financial debt
then that isn't as bad as your health
being damaged particularly um to to a
point where it could be fatal or you're
going to continue to see repeated
hospital admission so we would urge
people to try despite knowing how
incredibly difficult this is to keep at
least one home uh one room warm in the
home if um if if you can't achieve a
full level of warmth throughout your
property yeah certainly a tough winter
and a tough week for many people Peter
Smith from National energy action thank
you for joining us
thank you
time now for a look at the morning's
papers and the Metro leads with Prince
Harry's comments made in the highly
anticipated Netflix docu-series about
the sussexes that the Royals don't marry
for love
The Daily Express looks at the route
that has emerged over whether the Royals
were given a right of reply to the
couple's claims
and it'll surprise many of the papers
leading with the same story The Daily
Mail their headline Palace anger at
assault on the Queen's Legacy
in other news new anti-strike laws could
make industrial action worse the
government has admitted that's the claim
on the front page of the eye this
morning
and the financial times leads with the
Chancellor's plans to deregulate the
financial sector in a bid to drive
growth in the economy
welcome back she's safe and on a plane
that was the moment U.S President Joe
Biden announced that basketball star
Brittany Greiner had been released from
detention in Russia the White House
agreed to a prisoner swap handing over
notorious Russian arms dealer Victor
boot nicknamed The Merchant of death in
exchange for the WNBA player Miss
Greiner is expected to land back in the
U.S in the coming hours our U.S
correspondent James Matthews reports
from Russian TV the pictures that cried
Freedom this was Brittany Greiner
signing her release from jail
the U.S basketball star had been behind
Prison Walls for 10 months jailed in
February on drugs charging her release
was the Russian end of a prisoner
exchange deal that put her on a plane
home I'm good what's your name
[Music]
well are you ready for a flight yes yes
the flight to Freedom was rooted through
the United Arab Emirates these are
pictures of the prisoner swap as it
happened
walking one way on the tarmac was the
American heading in the other direction
was the man dubbed the merchant took
death
victim boot is a former Soviet military
officer serving a 25-year sentence in
the United States for illegal arms delay
the U.S president posted pictures of a
phone call to Welcome Home Brittany
Greiner an occasion to welcome her wife
to the White House she's safe she's on a
plane she's on her way home after months
of being unjustly detained in Russia
held under on tolerable circumstances
Brittany will soon be back in the arms
of her loved ones and and she should
have been there all along as we
celebrate bgba home we do understand
that there are still people out here who
are enduring what I endured the last
nine months of missing tremendously
their loved ones
Brittany Greiner is one of the biggest
names in American news and Sport a
player and a prisoner her Russian ordeal
began in a Moscow airport when she was
arrested for possessing cannabis oil in
her luggage
success in securing the release of one
American is tempered by the failure to
free a second Paul Whelan was jailed in
Russia in 2018 on spying charges which
he and his family refute I think
President Biden made the right decision
his job is to protect all Americans and
to care about all Americans and it would
have been wrong for him to leave behind
an American when he had the ability to
bring them home and so I appreciate that
he may have even waited he may have even
delayed in a hope that Paul might have
been able to come home but it was it was
absolutely the right decision to to
bring Ms Greiner home U.S Russian
negotiations for prisoner release
continue not helped by the war in
Ukraine in the freedom business it is a
complicating Factor James Matthews Sky
News Washington thanks Jackie now two
independent reports into alleged
corruption at one of the UK's largest
trade unions to be handed to the police
after potential criminality was
discovered
Sky News understands the two separate
inquiries into the unite Union found
evidence of eye-watering overcharging on
large contracts Joe Pike has this
exclusive report
because it's a fantastic investment and
you're the only one who's interested for
months they denied there were problems
you're doing yourself for incredible
disservice as a so-called journalists
with this nonsense and innuendos after
claims of corruption at one of the UK's
largest unions Labor's biggest donor
I don't believe I don't well don't get
in my face step don't get in my way
Glenn McCluskey is now retired as unite
General Secretary there is no suggestion
of wrongdoing on his part but his
successor has acted very differently
Sharon Graham rarely gives interviews
but she ran for the top job on a promise
to investigate if necessary obviously if
there was anything awry on that then I
would deal with that and she has
commissioning two reports which found
evidence of potential criminality
they're now being handed to the police
officers raided this building unites
London headquarters in April as part of
a fraud bribery and money laundering
investigation now police also have
access to these two independent reports
to help inform their work and I'm told
by One Source they contain details of
pricing and overcharging that would make
your eyes bleed
one report looked into the tens of
millions of pounds wasted on the unions
vastly over Budget Hotel and Conference
Center in Birmingham the development was
originally supposed to cost around 7
million pounds later rising to 57
million the final cost is now north of
98 million pounds one contractor was
found to have quoted around 90 000
pounds for work but was eventually paid
1.2 million an unexplained increase of 1
300 percent
the conservatives have written to labor
urging them to stop accepting money from
the union and return the 750 000 pounds
the party has received since the police
raid I look forward to the police doing
uh their work but the fact that Sharon
Graham has done this uh work has handed
it over the police I think shows that
the change that's happening in unite the
Union
a unite spokesperson has told Sky News
the general secretary is committed to
doing all in her power to recoup any
monies lost by all means necessary and
holding anyone responsible to account
whatever police do next if these reports
are right it seems unlikely that unite
will ever be able to fully recover the
millions of members money now missing
Joe Pike Sky News
let's have a look at some of the best
pictures around today and something
weird and wonderful to start your Friday
morning a porcelain toilet uh belonging
to John Lennon has been placed on show
at Liverpool's Beatles Museum now the
Lou was loaned to the museum museum
having been bought for only a thousand
pounds at auction the extravagant
extravagant piece featured in the
singer's Berkshire home which she shared
with Yoko Ono there you go porcelain
blue John Lennon's now this paddle
boarder
um clearer clearer doesn't feel the cold
clearly doesn't feel the cold I should
say
um they were photographed out on the
waters the sun rose over Avon beach in
Dorset yellow weather warnings for snow
and ice are in place for parts of the
country this weekend but there is a
beautiful yellow orange sky
and could this be Britain's most festive
home
this house in Bristol has been covered
in 50 000 lights including life-size
Santa's Snowman and elves clearly not
worried about energy bills in that
household
um and brothers Lee and Paul brailsford
spent six weeks turning their mum's home
into a winter wonderland something
they've apparently been doing for 27
years and it's all for charity they've
raised more than 90
000 pounds
so far um well certainly with houses
worrying about their energy energy costs
around the country we do want to get
your Christmas lights if you're creating
beautiful scenes like that but certainly
it looks like a heck of a lot of effort
to me
now
back to one of our top stories this
morning Royal Mail workers they're
beginning a new series of strikes which
could delay parcels and post in the
run-up to Christmas of course the
communication Workers Union which
represents Royal Mail employees says it
will continue with the disruption until
a settlement is agreed well joining me
now from the picket line in Parliament
square is the General Secretary of the
CWU Dave Ward thank you very much indeed
for joining us again Dave now you're on
this show last Thursday has anything
materially changed since then
um no nothing major uh the company we
met them earlier on in the week uh at
acass we're prepared to continue to meet
over the weekend
um the company made some moves and then
pulled them off the table around
extending job security we don't know why
they did that but they did suggest that
they were willing to extend job security
uh can I say Sally that you know this as
I've said in your show before but it
really is on behalf of 115 000 postal
workers hard-working decent people who
want nothing more than to be at work
they don't want to be out on strike over
Christmas and in this long-running
dispute but this really is the most
brutal attack on jobs that we've seen
any group of workers have to face in
this country they're seeing their jobs
their livelihood and the service that
they love providing to the public
they're seeing that being destroyed not
because we won't agree modernization but
because we won't agree to postal workers
being sat at the same time as the
company wants to bring in self-employed
drivers who have to pay for their own
Vans don't have proper contracts of
employment bringing new workers on 20
percent less terms and conditions and
retain around 11 000 agency workers not
not for Christmas but for all year round
at the same time our members want to
defend the service wrong now are not
modernizing the service they want to
start our delivery people three hours
later in the day that will mean they are
abandoning the am delivery period and
we're saying that is no way that this
business can survive in the future by
doing that it's the race to the bottom
in a way that I don't think we've ever
seen on the scale that we're seeing for
decades
Dave we hear your message loud and clear
but just in your resp in response uh to
what you were saying there about Royal
Mail workers being sacked a Royal Male
spokesperson did say that this is simply
not true that they'd already announced
reductions in 10 000 full-time
equivalent roles that simply this is uh
natural attrition what would you what
would you say to that
well so if what I'm saying is not true
then we could write a very simple
statement down now and all the things
that I've said Romel could commit to not
doing those things and we would find a
way forward in this dispute
um it's as simple as that but I wouldn't
believe what the company is saying
because this is a company that has taken
uh the whole of Royal Mail into a crisis
of their own making they had 758 million
pound profits only back in May and
within a matter of weeks they're
claiming that they're losing a million
pound a day that's not due to the
strikes that's due to their own gross
mismanagement of their finances
um so you know what I'm saying to you
and every postal worker will attest to
that as to why they're out on strike
today is true they've lost complete
confidence in the leadership of Royal
Mail a handful of people are not
interested in running the service that
they love to provide to the public
let's just go over the detail
um if I may Dave what is the pay
increase currently on offer and what is
it that you're asking for
well if I could put it this way I think
first of all I want to say this and I'm
sure postal workers would back me up on
this is that if they offered 50 pay but
still put the same terms and conditions
in front of our members our members
wouldn't agree because the simple
reality is they are destroying the
service on pay I'll come to that the
company is saying they've offered nine
percent over 18 months what they've
offered is seven percent plus a 500
pound lump sum and we have said
continuously and I'm not one for
negotiating live on air but we have said
honestly and continuously if it was a
proper nine percent uh fully backdated
the full value of that nine percent go
into postal workers and if the change
was the right change for our members and
crucially for customers and the future
of this company then we would probably
find a settlement on that figure
foreign
the Royal Mail boss Simon Thompson is
Accused you he's accused union bosses
such as yourself as of resisting change
is modernization not needed
well it depends what you call
modernization uh we don't believe
modernization is destroying decent
hard-working people's jobs we don't
believe it's replacing those with people
on Lower terms and conditions we don't
believe it's destroying a service that
has got an unrivaled reach we deliver to
32 million addresses a day all they want
to do is turn Royal Mail into just
another parcel courier company like
every they're competing on the race to
the bottom rather than competing with
their natural Advantage which is a great
Workforce who will be out in force today
at Parliament Square postal workers your
viewers know these people
um this is not about unions not a green
change this is about a company that has
lost its way lost the support of the
workforce and haven't got a plan for the
future other than satisfying major
shareholders most of them don't even
come from the UK
um and just before I let you go Dave can
I just ask what other unions uh you've
been working with to coordinate uh this
industrial action
well in actual fact we we haven't sat
down uh and said at this stage uh we'll
culminate the strike we'll call this the
other Union will call that strike but
look let me say as well you know we
support all workers who are on strike
for us in CWU I think for the whole of
the country at the moment every single
worker counts I think people are just
getting to a point where they're seeing
businesses the government in in the case
of the railways the nurses teachers not
responding to very simple requests to
try and treat people who treat the rest
of society fairly to do the same with
with their own group of workers in our
case you know I mean we believe that we
want to to create a future for Royal
Mail we care about the customers you
could speak to any postal workers I
promise you this and they will say that
they care about the service they provide
they've got great ideas on how Royal
Mail can continue to be a major
contributor to the UK economy overlaying
new products new Services uh you know
what I think would would help us here is
if we actually shifted the balance of
forces in the world at work
um postal workers and customers were on
the board of this company and maybe many
other companies around the UK then I
think you'd get better Services better
pay better terms and conditions and we
wouldn't have the strikes that we're all
unfortunately being involved in at the
moment
Dave we appreciate you joining us time
to go and get a cup of tea and warm up
Dave Ward thank you very much for your
time
thanks very much
bye
TSB has today become the first bank to
launch an emergency flea fund to help
victims of domestic violence Escape
abusive relationships it comes as new
figures from the charity Hestia show
that three in Four Women affected by
domestic violence say the cost of living
crisis has either prevented or made it
even harder for them to leave well I'm
joined Now by domestic abuse
commissioner Nicole Jacobs certainly a
very serious story indeed Nicole thank
you for joining us what are you hearing
I am hearing very much the same you know
we know from women's Aid England which
is of course one of our main uh bodies
that represents many many services in
England uh the same which is that people
are finding it much much harder to leave
if they need to
um as as you said uh 73 telling us that
um they're finding it really difficult
to leave their perpetrator because of
these worries of a cost of living and of
course domestic abuse is associated a
part and parcel with financial abuse so
we know that victims of domestic abuse
often don't have access to money that
they've earned are highly monitored in
terms of
um of day-to-day finances and often just
don't have that access to that little
bit of money that can help get them away
and get them to safety so explain if you
if you can how this emergency flea fund
may work
well it's based on something that
women's Aid Refuge surviving economic
abuse and others and I have been calling
government to put in place which is a
flexible funding part for survivors who
are in a crisis or victims of domestic
abuse in a crisis who need to get from
point A to point B or really have that
encouragement that it's even possible
um during this cost of living crisis to
leave their abuser so TSB amazingly has
stepped in for its customers and have
said that they will set up that type of
a fund for its customers so I think it
represents a huge step forward it shows
us it's possible and that it's needed
that's very very clear by the evidence
and we need to see this go further and
have the government really step up and
and do the same for the of course the
vast majority of victims of domestic
abuse who are facing a daunting winter
ahead of them
and Nicole just briefly um if someone is
watching and experiencing abuse what's
your advice to them
my advice is absolutely there's help
available please reach out we have our
national helplines
um we have you will have websites in
your own area as Hestia who partners
with TSB has pointed out there's you
know TSB branch and locations pharmacies
that offer safe spaces there's
increasingly
um you know safe spaces online web chats
there's all sorts Jacobs we'll have to
leave it there thank you so much for
joining us thank you